we're here at Basel world which is the
world's largest watches and jewelry fair
brands like Patek Phillipe Rolex Tudor
Tag Heuer all come to show their latest
wares we've been all around the fair and
we found the coolest five this timepiece
is the M BNF hmx black badger which is a
watch that NB NF came out with last year
but this year they partnered with the
artist designer James Thompson aka black
badger to come up with a super powerful
new loom which is brighter and will last
longer than any other loom on the market
there are three colors of this watch and
only 18 of each color will be made this
is the regatta OT USA watch from
Bremen's it's a very handsome sailing
launch it actually has a functioning
regatta movement up top which counts
down has Loom around the bezel which
looks very cool if you're sailing at
night and it actually when sold will
have a piece of the America's Cup
winning sailboat which will be put on
top of this crown a little bit of a foil
from the boat and only 235 of these will
be made this is a completely new watch
for Patek Phillipe it's a combination
world time and chronograph it was
inspired by a watch that's actually in
the Patek
museum from the 1940s it's also the
thinnest and smallest world time
paragraph on the working
Graff has made a brand-new perpetual
calendar watch this year it's the first
other fav made and they've been really
ambitious with it you can see it's got
the big flying tourbillon at 6 o'clock
it's got a big date indicator leap year
indicator here and on the back you can
see the the rotor is actually integrated
into the movement it's off to the side
which is our usual and ball around the
edges of the bezel are these are
have fires
every year Tag Heuer takes vintage watch
from their Museum it makes a
contemporary watch that was inspired by
it so this year tag has made the Tag
Heuer monza which is named after the
racetrack in Italy and it looks like a
watch that the racer Niki Lauda wore
we need one that the race at Monza in
1975 it's a little bigger than that
watch was but it carries a lot of the
same elements and it has that great
vintage look